[Music]
it's a tense workplace environment that
you're in
okay how do you relax I mean I come in
here and it's laughs and giggles the
occasional awkward silence but for the
most part a lot of fun you're going to a
workplace where people want to kill each
other you're revealing someone else I
want to kill me yeah they want to kill
you
how do you relax what they've started
giving me they they give me like passes
to get massages oh okay but I will tell
you this the place they are sending me
is backfiring every time because I go to
this Thai massage and this woman who is
walking on my back oh that kind of
massage but all she does is complain
about how long the walk is she starts
walking and she gets tired and she'll
say you're so long and I actually have a
curved spine so she says she's walking
uphill occasionally she'll say she'll
add oil and just slide back into my butt
so it becomes the worst I have more
stress coming at it it's it's probably
easier to summit Everest than Kirk Fox
yeah I would think so and so you should
probably stop going to this place I
can't it's free all right well now you
have this show and you really do use
polygraph you use a lie detector on the
show are people asking you because I've
always found lie detectors fascinating
are people coming up to you I would do
it if I you know backstage I'd say so
how can you beat a lie detector I'm
curious how people can do it but what's
funny is couples are coming up to me now
everyone wants relationship advice and
everyone that comes up to me asks me the
same question how can we beat the
polygraph but that's that's all they
want to know see that's their
relationship advice yes they want to
build a stronger relationship it's so
that they can get away with cheating I
guess right that's terrible that's a bad
sign listen you asked the question I'm
just giving you
listen III didn't say it was pretty no
you didn't you didn't s you did not say
it was pretty and it's the world we live
in it turns out that everyone most
people are getting caught cheating
because they're sending pictures on the
phone yes Siwan sewage Joe lost his job
at the at the sewage department for
sending dick pics but watch the language
what's the language I don't know where
you think we are right now this is not
sudden so it's not some massage parlor I
thought was New York in the 80s it was
much easier to cheat I think in in the
old days because if you wanted to sext
or send a picture of yourself you'd
actually have to draw it and then you'd
only get caught if you signed it
yeah so it's a different time you have
to draw it sign it and then get on a
course and take it you know eight days
by the time you cheated the person
you're cheating on would probably be
dead
yes sure in the 1800s those were better
times
well because everyone had a mustache
that now you've done it you've gone too
far